we're [ __ ] ever happened to me on my uh
this is duck the six-week anniversary of
this alright I was flying to Washington
and to do next to me [ __ ] his pants yeah
[ __ ] his pants and it wasn't like yeah
but you would be like oh my god you can
have some apathy in this dude this is my
gun like a like a nougat maybe like a
you know because he didn't know you know
so this smell was walking up to me I
mean 15 [ __ ] minutes and when you
smell that you're like and it wasn't a
fart because we all know what a fart
farts have a tinge an age in SA quoi if
I may we know what a fart in a matter
where you are in the world so my part
you can be like somebody farted who
farted this was like between fart and
open baby diaper it looks like you know
and now I'm getting mad cuz this dude
shitty pants over here you know I'm like
the [ __ ] got turn this thing on
I got the credit card application I come
in a black church this is a lot of man
I'm gonna have my you know shitty pants
sees me doing this and he goes are you
okay dude I'm like man I don't know
there's some kind of like flatulent
situation I didn't want to be crass on
the plane so I said flatulence and he
goes on to bet he turns his thing on it
pointed at me okay two hours later
shitty pants gets up to go to the
bathroom
it turns the can in towards me that's
when I knew that this [ __ ] I
wanna [ __ ] his pants
now he's walking back to the [ __ ]
crop-dusting the whole plane now when he
came back to his seat at that moment he
knew he should his man and he knew that
I knew he should his man so I was giving
him that you [ __ ] your pants face how
are we doing over here man
make matters worse I tell my mom about
it right get off the plane to go mine to
do next me [ __ ] his pants my mom's you
know what your mother says [ __ ] to you
that you just want to like set her on
fire and I'm talking about no sympathy
she says well what did the airline deal
Mach there's no [ __ ] your pants run
along it's not during the safety talk
where they like you know emergency exits
are here in the event you [ __ ] your man
I swear to you she thought the cabin was
gonna be like she captain uh you an
emergency situation eight B has [ __ ] his
hair I'm gonna take her down to Toledo
[ __ ] man